from 9 to 19 years old as I was in the
series like that's a massive
period of your life where like a lot is
going on I mean you're really growing up
yeah and you still have a lot to do I
mean 19 is still young you know so but
those are like that's 10 years of your
life that's half of your first 19 years
you're on set you're experiencing this
world Fame how did you take it like when
did people recognize you instantly
yeah I mean obviously as the character
grew it was like an inevitable
um uh thing that would grow into being
more recognizable I mean I feel on the
scale of
some of the other actors I feel
you know I had a relatively like I could
still
have a normal life you know I took the
tube to school and I went you know I
lived in the heart of London and I was
kind of out and about and doing my thing
you know there were some days where you
did suddenly be like oh my God I want to
you know run away and